let's think about what would happen
inside of china if the government were
to allow its currency to completely
float against the dollar so we know that
the byproduct would be its currency
would strengthen because so far they've
been artificially weakening it so you
would have a stronger
a stronger join and you would have a
weaker and you would have a weaker
dollar i want to be clear the chinese
government actually has been allowing
the u.n to slowly strengthen against the
dollar but it keeps maintaining a peg we
want to just think about what happens if
it were to completely float now the
obvious byproduct of this we know that
when it kept the currency weak that'll
that favored its exports it allowed its
exports to be cheaper creating demand
for the exports now if they allowed
their currency to strengthen then their
exports would be more expensive in other
countries so it would decrease
it would decrease demand for exports now
with fewer exports fewer production
perhaps in their factories now this
obviously would slow down this would
slow down the chinese economy slow down
economy
now this we have to be careful here when
we say slow down this doesn't mean that
they'll necessarily fall into a
recession they've been growing at the
high single digits to low double digits
for many many many years now when we
talk about slowing down they might slow
down to maybe four or five percent
growth which is still super fast by any
other nation standards
we've also seen that there's a ton of
inflation in china and to some degree
that kind of hints that the chinese
consumer is ready to take up the slack
from foreign consumers so it might not
even slow down as as as we might i guess
at first think and that brings up maybe
the first unambiguous positive behind
allowing their currency to strengthen if
they were to actually stop printing when
and buying other currencies it would
actually slow down inflation it would
actually slow down inflation and already
we we know that they're getting
dangerously
close to kind of an inflationary spiral
that they they've been reporting five
six percent inflation the reality might
be closer to ten percent and the
inflation is actually going to be
mitigated not just from the fact that
you have less when running around but
and and the economy slowing down but
it's also because the wind is
strengthening and when it's stronger it
allows them to buy imports more cheaply
and for the chinese perhaps the most
important import or imports are
commodities and the most important of
the commodities is oil so the price of
oil would go down
now a bigger question this one's harder
to answer is what happens to chinese
manufacturing in general
manufacturing a lot of people the
argument why china was able to build its
manufacturing bases it had this weak
currency and that allowed it to build
these ecosystems and get to scale at it
in its factories will the manufacturing
then go back to the u.s or europe my
my gut is is that it wouldn't go back to
the u.s and europe because anything that
requires huge amount of scale and huge
amount of labor is going to be very hard
for the chinese to compete with the
chinese even if their currency was
stronger i think at that point china is
going to have to worry about other
developing nations maybe india maybe
latin america where they have labor
advantages relative to china and if they
were able to kind of have the same
efficiencies in the same infrastructure
in the same scale they might be able to
give them a run for their money this is
salman khan of the khan academy for cnbc